hello everyone in the headlines this
month dystopian societies to sanity zero
well at least according to some reports
in other news it's time for a change in
Wellington wells
welcome to the clockwork update for we
happy few
this update focuses on improving what's
currently in the game finally fixes
parity and has a few new places to
explore let's get into it
[Music]
[Music]
first we have a small surprise for you
as you know at the end of the prologue
Arthur gets smoked by a couple of
bobbies and left for dead
we haven't revealed what happens next
until now
from now on Arthur will wake up right
where we left off you'll explore a brand
new tutorial area designed to introduce
players to the coming woes of fending
for your life in the Garden District we
also hope this helps answer the how the
[ __ ] did we get down here question
players have been asking themselves in
previous builds so while you graciously
impatiently anticipate the full
narrative release we hope you'll enjoy
this repaired plot hole in the meantime
sicken to help prevent bugs caused by
quests going absolutely haywire we have
implemented conversation mode thank you
previously cheering and encounter it was
kind of easy to break a quests condition
for example you could kill the NPC right
in the middle of him talking to you or
you could walk away and still be
assigned the objective for no real
reason
all the NPC would be taken down by
another MVC or you were attacked which
frankly is much more likely because
knowing you guys you probably just hit
someone in the face now once you start
talking to an encounter NPC she will
enter conversation mode and nothing from
the outside can interfere with that
conversation this makes for a far more
cinematic feeling because each of these
conversations is like a mini cutscene it
means we can create more engaging
animation and make sure that the right
information is getting across to the
player yes it does mean that you can't
take down NPCs while they are talking
however you can do that afterwards and
sometimes before if you like you cheek
third for a couple of months now the
team has been working hard on
refactoring all of our current
encounters what this means is that we
have completely changed how the
encounters and quests are built in the
game previously each level designer on
the team had their own method of
scripting things but because all of this
was different if something broke
we couldn't repair it globally so this
update introduces a new quest state
system that allows us to streamline
everything this system makes it much
easier for the game to know exactly
where you are in a quest this means
fewer bugs in the encounters and a
significantly simplified and faster safe
system please be aware that you will
need to start a new game with this
update as the old system is completely
incompatible fourth while politely
pillaging the village of Hamelin you may
notice it's received a nice fresh
facelift courtesy of the humble and
entirely good-looking art team together
we created new furniture wallpapers
paintings and countless other little
details to make the village feel more
authentic the more this place looks like
Carnaby Street had a freakish baby with
mr. Bean's apartment the better
that means the interiors got some major
TLC not only to make them look more
beautiful but to better support gameplay
an environmental storytelling in order
to do this we made props like reminder
notes and custom book covers but we also
carefully adjusted the lighting to
create a better atmosphere and optimized
layout and I mean a lot of these major
changes are purely aesthetic the
villagers are still going to hate you if
you look like you're trespassing but
when they aren't trying to beat the crap
out of you they'll go about their
business instead of wandering around
like brainless idiots
and finally as usual there are a whole
bunch of little changes for example we
have added a few new animations that
will help spice things up as you're
wandering around Wellington wells we
hope that these little details plus the
huge changes to our quests and
encounters will make the game a much
better overall experience and we do hope
that you enjoy it
hi I'm Sarah this is Sam we're not
deeply uncomfortable on camera we work
here I can Austin kagan's we figured you
guys might be interested in taking a
look behind the scenes at what goes on a
compulsion
we're basically 25 people down a
Montreal and Canada and yeah we make we
happy few we take your feedback really
seriously and I know it might not seem
like very much but we changed the game
quite a bit
thanks to feedback you guys were giving
us previously the best place to give
feedback is either on the steam forums
or on the compulsion Gamescom forums
thanks for your time